hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft facts heute am
dienstag mal pünktlich
ich habe mir wieder perfekt rausgesucht
die immer per mail an contractor
gmail.com geschrieben habt danke an euch
es sind wieder sehr sehr coole sachen
dabei und irgendwann in dieser folge
wird wieder ein geheimnisvolles geräusch
auftauchen also black screen wo ich ein
geräusch vorlese und ihr könnt ihr dann
in die kommentare schreiben was das denn
für ein geräusch gewesen sein soll und
das werdet ihr dann schon irgendwann im
video erfahren und ich würde sagen wir
von direkt mit den fake sich haben mal
wieder nicht sagen ob die fed sich schon
in anderen videos vorgekommen sind oder
ob ihr das ganze schon kennt und so was
alles und eventuell kennt ihr auch schon
alles was ich vor stelle aber sind auf
jeden fall ganz coole sache nicht fangen
direkt mit dem ersten effekt zugesendet
von david und zwar in der folge von 85
wenn ihr euch daran ändern könnte habe
ich gesagt wenn wir auf die kiste drauf
springt und man es liegt dann fällt man
runter so er hat mir allerdings
geschrieben wenn man zwei kisten
übereinander stellt das geht auch mit
ändert es beispielsweise dann wenn ich
da oben drauf sneaker ihr seht das so
zackig mache dass wir ihn so zackig
zwickl und ich bleibe hier stehen also
ich kann euch jetzt schlecht zeigen dass
ich weiter geradeaus laufen einfach nur
auf der karte stehen bleibe aber testen
ist doch einfach mal selbst in zwei
kisten beieinanderstehen geht das ganze
mit dem sneak nämlich einwandfrei und
das ist sehr sehr krass und zwar ich
meine es ist der gleiche blog es ist der
gleiche blockiert um den block herum ist
nix und darum die blogger sonics nur
einfach dass darunter noch ein blog ist
dass das macht das ganze dass da zwei
kissen über dann dastehen das ist schon
sehr sehr sehr coole sache dann kann
dich da wird dass ihr das aufgefallen
ist weil ich denke habe ich ein paar
gefragt ob bei mir gehts doch also dann
kann ich damit der zweite effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von elias und zwar sagt
elias dass wenn ich hier ich habe es ja
schon mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst
runterspringen keinen fall schreinert
nicht mehr gepasst konzerts springen
keinen fall schade wenn man sich aus
lockt als ich da ganz oben ein blogger
gestellt ich will ganz hoch denn ich bin
im kreativ
hallo blog ich bin mir relativ weit oben
ihr seht das sind so ein paar bugs vom
shader den muss ich noch ein bisschen
bearbeiten
wenn ich jetzt runter fallen trade off
mode passiert ja nichts deswegen setze
ich mich mal ganz kurz in den gamern 0
unterfalle denke abkommen dasteht ich
hoffe ich kann das jetzt alles zeitnahe
hier so ein bisschen versuchen richtig
zu machen und zwar wenn ich mich kurz
vor dem boden auslage bekomme ich keinen
fall schaden soll ich bin jetzt mal ganz
kurz runter
ich bin scheiße aber ich will kaka hatte
ich mach's nochmal bevor sie also denkt
dass ich total doof bin einfach mal die
größte mülltonne die ich kenne wo wir es
noch mal also ich stelle hier oben ihr
müsst euch kurz vom boden aus logen so
das perfekte ist perfekt jetzt klick auf
speichern und zurück zum menü sag dir
meine welt
hierunter und ihr seht zack und ich
bekomme keinen fall schaden
das ist nämlich sehr also bekommt dann
einfach gar keinen fall schaden mit den
wehren aus der höhe und hat das geile
daran ist einfach wenn ihr das
beispielsweise ich bin grad in der
version 1.4 er spielt in der version 1.5
das heißt da gibt's auch noch wenn ihr
beispielsweise von einer klippe
runterfällt und ihre realität so vor
escape brückensprengung zurück wieder
dran keinen fall schaden da ist der
sache dann kann der dritte und vierte
feld kommen beide von matthias der mir
sieben richtig coole sachen geschickt
habe ich hab mir davon jetzt mal zwei
rausgesucht und war die erste sache ihr
kennt das wenn ich weizenkörner in die
hand nehme
sie sind die ganzen hühner schafe auf
mich soll die comics mehr an weil ihr
wisst ja weizenkörner sowie für die wak
feldtor männer die brauchen das um zu
kicken
wenn ich allerdings netter watson in die
hand nehme oder im blog daneben liefert
will der denn jetzt das ist genau sie
wenn ihr im gleichen jugendlichen der
alte oma hinreichend ja auch kein bock
zu [ __ ]
allerdings erkennt es mit weizen und
zack beiden lieben sich und ich bin
immer noch im game mode 0 und ich gebe
auch erste game im 1 die beiden lieben
sich ein kleines kind gemacht
minerva warzen geht das auch also ich
kann die beiden ihr tipp an die lieben
sicherheits und tag wie ein kleines
mädchen
ich weiß nicht ob es so und so auch geht
ja das geht auch ihr könnt auch netter
warzen watson netter wachsen und weil zu
können
das funktioniert auch hier noch mal zu
sehen so zac und jetzt haben wir vier
kleine baby münchen also danke an dich
matthias für diesen sehr sehr sehr sehr
cool effect ist echt regeln richtig
richtig geile sache dass man hühnchen
auch mit netter warzen oder paaren kann
finde ich auf jeden fall sehr sehr cool
da kann sich matthias so damit sind wir
auch schon bei dem geheimnisvollen
geräusch angelangt und zwar wurde das
letzte geheimnisvolle geräusche zweimal
so crazy es haben einfach 99 5 prozent
das geräusch nicht erraten
dann kam kommentare an wie du wenn du
dir einen runter holt oder das war eine
chipstüte oder blatt papier oder keine
ahnung ich bin alle seiten durchgegangen
ich glaub christoph schmidt war der
einzige jetzt erhalten hat du hast den
tempo taschentuch packung aufgemacht
haben dass man so viele erwarten dass
ich nie dieses wort an sich suchen
musste ich habe die ganzen kommentare
aufgerufen habe nur taschentuch
eingegeben da kam nur christophs
kommentar aber egal vielleicht habe
diesmal ein bisschen mehr glück jetzt
ist diesmal ein bisschen einfacher
und zwar das geheimnisvolle geräusche
diesmal dass hier so viel glück beim
erraten kann zwar direkt in die
kommentare schreiben dann ist eure
chance größer dass in der nächsten folge
werde blablabla viel spaß andere als gut
ich lieber schaut der vierte fake wurde
mir wie gerade eben schon gesagt
ebenfalls von matthias zugesendet und
zwar hab ich mir gerade eine neue welt
gemacht sieht übrigens sehr sehr cool
aus als mit dem shader finde ich und da
werde ich jetzt mal ganz kurz einen
ender dragons bonn
ihr wisst es okay die ränder dragon ist
so wie ein zombie oder eine spinne ich
bin doch ein bisschen anders sowieso
einen zombie oder ein krieg oder in
skelett die sind nur in der nacht da und
die hassen euch auch einfach dass man
diese mops die einfach böse sind was
flattert denn da oben so rum weil das
einfach so ein kleiner licht spielt sehr
sehr schön hier sagt ich das bereits
ich mag ich hier allerdings ihr weg ich
bin im friedlichen modus wenn ich jetzt
hier ich es gibt keinen ender dreck oder
so aber es gibt den begriff ändert
dragon und ihr wisst ich bin im
friedlichen modus kann objekt nicht
erzeugen
sehr geil ein moment okay ich habe
einfach die gleiche kommentar normal
eingegeben aber dass die berner drängen
groß gemacht also zusammen ändert reagan
dann könnt ihr einen ändert drachen
spawn und ihr seht ich bin im
friedlichen - und er macht trotzdem
alles kaputt der unterschied ist
allerdings also das krass ist einfach
dass man ändert bringen auch in peace
von modus poren kann
aber welche zweite x games 04 greift
nämlich trotzdem nicht an der fliegt
zwar auf mich zu ihr teilweise kenne man
bisher in bekämpfen die sich jetzt das
wäre premium kann hier die flieger ist
auch dazu die können aber keinen schaden
zufügen
die machen nur meiner umwelt kaputt wenn
ich allerdings das ganze jetzt auf
einfach setzte dann greift nämlich schon
an und hoffentlich das liegt ja diese
schwierigkeit modus ich kann es jetzt
hier wieder umstellen hatte die sag ich
mal eingreifen damit ihr das seht so
will irgendwer hier stelle ich das ganze
mal wieder auf friedlich dann sind die
immer noch da die diesmal nicht so wie
indianer mops sondern die greift mich
dann halt nur nicht mehr an beziehungen
also die können wir keinen schaden mehr
zufügen
das ist ganz geil und auf jeden fall
dann kann ich matthias und dann will ich
schon sagen dass es sehr sehr laut dir
und mir reden sie dann erst folge mein
stoffwechsel zeit gefallen hat zeigt
sein mag ich schaff mir 3000 mag ich bei
der letzten folge war es auch wieder
viel mehr das ist der enkel von euch
gewesen ist seitdem ganze community ich
kenne und vielleicht habt ihr das
geheimnisvolle geräusch mitbekommen auch
erraten dann schreibt auf jeden fall in
die kommentare von crafter gmail.com die
töten hier noch ein bisschen meine welt
und dann würde ich sagen wunderschönen
tag und deutschland gestern 720 gewonnen
erstes land der welt